thank you is foreign
nothing days
[Music]
security situations
universities
foreign
thank you so much for the warm welcome
let me also thank the government of
Lithuania and the people of Lithuania
for hosting the upcoming Summit here in
Venus
this week at the NATO Summit we will
strengthen our turns and defense
including with more investment we will
step up our support for Ukraine and move
Ukraine closer to Nato
and we will work even more closely with
Partners to support the rules based in
National order
I was lost here in Lithuania just two
weeks ago together we met Lithuanian and
German troops participating in exercise
within storm
demonstrating our ability to reinforce
our presence in Lithuania
to Brigade the science
at the summit we will take further major
steps to strengthen our deterrence and
defense
including three new Regional plans
backed by 300 troops on high redness and
major capabilities across all domains
this sends a care message that we will
defend every inch of Lithuania and every
inch of Allied territory
we will also take decisions on Ukraine
this includes a multi-air package of
assistance to transition from Soviet era
to Nato equipment and standards making
the ukrainians forces fully
interoperable with allies
uncovering critical needs like demining
equipment Fuel and medical supplies
we will also upgrade our political ties
president zelensky will join us for the
inaugural meeting of the new NATO
Ukraine Council
and tomorrow allies will address
Ukraine's path towards NATO membership
to continue supporting Ukraine and
strengthening our own forces we need to
invest more in defense
so allies will set a more ambitious
defense investment page building online
consecutive years of increased defense
spending across European allies and
Canada
this includes the rise of 8.3
in real terms this year the biggest
increase in defense spending in decades
we will also meet with our close
partners and business the European Union
and leaders of Australia New Zealand
Japan and South Korea
this will be finland's first summit as a
NATO Ally I will look forward to Sweden
joining as soon as possible
later today as the next step in this
process
so president thank you again for your
hospitality and lithuania's many
contributions to Nato thank you
okay we'll start with the political
lady in green
um thank you very much I have a question
both for the Secretary General and the
president
um Ukraine's Minister kuleba tweeted
earlier today that NATO allies have
reached consensus on removing map but he
also added that it is the best moment to
offer Clarity on the invitation to
Ukraine to become a member so I was
wondering if you could both update us on
where those discussions are and what
concretely the alliance can offer
Ukraine at this stage when it comes to
the prospect of membership thank you so
consultations are going on and there
will be all the meetings taking place
today but I'm confident that all allies
will agree on the very declare message
also when it comes to Ukraine
um no final decision has been made but
uh at the same time absolutely so
certain that we'll have a unity and a
strong message on Ukraine
one was to have a program of practical
support to ensure full interoperability
between Ukrainian forces and NATO forces
this will move Ukraine closer to Nato
the other element was also to establish
the NATO Ukraine Council uh this is a
platform to consult and also to uh to
take to make decisions together and the
third element was to remove the
requirements for the membership action
plan turning the membership process for
Ukraine um
moving it from a two-step process to a
one-step process and now we are
discussing these elements on this
package and also
finalizing the discussions and the
negotiations on the precise language so
I will not go into the details about
what allies are in the process of
agreeing but I welcome the fact that we
are now building on the package that was
launched in Oslo and I'm confident that
we have a good and strong and positive
message when the leaders meet
um
[Music]
experience
with specific political decisions
I'm sorry
that Ukraine will become a member of the
alliance and I'm confident that that
Summit will make decisions which will be
uh strong and positive on Ukraine and we
are now discussing this package that was
launched in Oslo of practical support to
enable full interoperability between
Ukrainian forces and Native forces
stronger political ties with the NATO
Council and then the removal of the
membership action plan and of course
this is about moving Ukraine closer to
uh to uh to membership but again the
defined decisions will be taken when
every Ally when we all agree and and the
leaders meet
tomorrow so it's too early to announce
exactly the specific decisions and the
specific language
[Music]
it is important to communicate that
Allah that Ukraine will become a member
of the alliance but we also agree that
NATO store remains open and we have
demonstrated that by inviting Finland
and Sweden to become members and we have
and finance all the full member and we
have also rated it again and again that
of course it is for the allies and
Ukraine to decide when the time is right
to invite Ukraine to be a full member
the most
urgent task now is to ensure that
Ukraine prevails as a sovereign an
independent nation in Europe because
unless Ukraine prevails then there is no
membership issue to be discussed at all
so I think it's extremely important that
we continue to ensure that allies are
providing weapons ammunition training
spare parts and to Ukraine so they are
able to liberate more land but also to
deter Russia from further regression
foreign
[Music]
organizations
front row here
yesterday
in general and the president
um we here now a report from turkey that
Erwin is actually connecting a future EU
membership for turkey will Sweden's
accession to to Nato what do you think
about that and if Sweden doesn't get a
yes from Irwin at this Summit do you
then feel that this can drag on for a
very long time
I support turkey's Ambitions to become a
member of the European Union at the same
time we need to remember that what we
agreed in Madrid was a specific list of
conditions that Sweden has to meet to be
a full member of the alliance and Sweden
has met these conditions and that's
about
removing restrictions on arms exports
that has happened then it's about
strengthening the cooperation between
turkey and
Sweden on fighting terrorism that's
taking place and Sweden has also amended
its Constitution and strengthened the
country types of laws and uh and and
Sweden is following up to address a
legitimate security concerns by turkey
and it is important that we stand
together in the fight against terrorism
but at the same time it's also important
that we address the legitimate security
concerns of all allies that I don't want
to say Sweden as a member of the
alliance as soon as possible because
this will strengthen
NATO and it will strengthen our ability
to defend and protect not least the
Baltic region if you just look at the
map because sweetness as a full member
in addition to Finland really changes
the geography the
NATO presence in this this region so so
we are working hard to get a Sweden uh
other members as soon as possible I met
with the president at Ron a few weeks
ago we had constructive and good talks
we agreed that that meeting to convene
the permanent mechanism the mechanism
that was established over by Sweden
Finland NATO and and turkey they met a
few days ago in in Brussels also there
we were able to make some progress and
then I'm looking forward to meeting
President and uh
later on today and and it's still
possible to have a positive decision on
Swedish membership ahead in business you
don't have any YouTube we don't have any
guarantees but of course now we have the
momentum of the summit with the
leadership and we will use that momentum
to ensure as much progress as possible
yeah and um
[Music]
um
facilitates our common operations
of the question for Secretary General
and president about brigades in the NATO
Eastern flank um Germany promised
Brigade in Romania Canada or promised in
Latvia do you see the need of more
formal agreements or declarations for
establishment of these plans in a NATO
format
so NATO has already increases presence
in the Baltic region we established some
years ago the three no the four bath
groups then after the invasion of uh of
Ukraine the full scaling nation of
Ukraine last year we doubled the number
of bat groups in eastern part of the
alliance and we also made the decision
at the Madrid Summit that these
particles should be scalable of the
Brigade size levels meaning we need
dedicated forces with dedicated
responsibilities and also exercises and
uh and uh and and prepositioned
equipment and the infrastructure in
place to quickly is to be scaled up to
battle group size and that's exactly
what I saw myself at the exerciser in
Lithuania two weeks ago the ability of
NATO allies in this case Germany to
scale up the Brigade size level and then
of course that was a welcome the
announcement by Germany and that they
are ready to uh I have one Brigade
for uh for Lithuania
um deployed and uh and uh and I welcomed
that when it was announced to uh two
weeks ago and in nature we were at this
meeting at this Summit uh tomorrow on
the day after tomorrow we will agree new
defense spans we will agree a new force
model a new Force structure and the four
structure requirements to execute and to
to meet the needs to protect and defend
all allies so the the details of related
or posture presence will be described
there but we welcome the uh the all the
increased persons that has been
announced in the Baltic region Germany
foreign
[Music]
is
thank you
one second